if you're part of the lgbtq community
okay if you are
where are you better off florida or
california
florida
what do you think i'm actually curious
zero clue i don't know i'm not part of
that community you were hanging out with
them that's why i know
but actually think about it i don't know
think about where are they going to be
better off in florida or california
well let me ask a question a different
way
where are you better off if you're
running a business florida or california
florida florida okay where are you
better if you can't stand we're in a
mask
florida
where are you better if you are part of
the lgbtq community i would say
california because they're very it's
what is florida doing to actively
discriminate against lgbt exactly where
i'm not thinking
you've seen the thing don't say gay
right
again don't say gay
the whole thing but by the way by the
way
when you poach which is what he's doing
and what desantis is doing this is a
poaching game okay
when you're poaching
who's desantis poaching
californians business owners correct
yeah come here open up yeah listen come
over here business owners who are
independent responsible you and me yeah
who is newsome trying to poach
people that the people that are just
leaving the state so
but i'm actually being very serious who
is he trying to poach
who's he so he's he's targeting lgbtq
community fine that's the community you
want to put what what other community so
do you think his argument for business
owners
leaving florida to california how many
business owners do you think will leave
florida to go to california after that
speech yeah let me think zero tell me
what i'm being serious
how can you poach them is he gonna poach
guys that don't like high taxes is he
gonna poach guys that are willing to go
out there and start a business and you
know is he gonna poach those guys he's
not no so his campaign
who you think is going to watch that and
be inspired to want to come to your
state he's recruiting victims none of
the people you want so guess what the
descent is if you're recruiting victims
and if i am desantis and newsome says
this if newsom said that if i'm desantis
i say go go to california
my campaign would be very simple if you
like high taxes if you like a ton of
entitlement programs
if you like to be forced to take the
vaccine if you like to be forced to put
on the mask if you want to i have a
great state for you to move to it's
called uh california if you like the
worst homelessness
fyi fyi if i'm the the
leader of the republican party the
conservative party right now and i'm not
talking about like i'm talking about
strategists behind closed doors the
campaign people guess what i'm doing i'm
getting all the state governors together
and i'm saying guys what's the one state
you're never going to win and it doesn't
matter anyways california why don't you
send everybody a one-way greyhound
ticket straight to california let's fund
it you know what that does that locks in
your state okay
let's sell california is the state to
move if you're the following category
it's brilliant go for it
and you start driving it hey listen you
feel like that you should move to
california you should move to california
you should move to california you should
move to california you should go to
california yeah and then business owners
gonna be like but if you're this this
this you should move to florida you
should move to tennessee you should move
to texas you should move to this
i'm one of those people too uh as i was
reading that being the person that just
moved here from california pat i'm sorry
but
i'm going back you he sold me right
there you're right you're rescinding um
you know what
take that offer you know where you can
go i'm going back because you know i
want the homelessness i want the taxes i
want because you know the second
pandemic is coming and trust me if you
want to be in a [ __ ] place that stays
to what you know faucina say i'm going
back to fourth and back to cali so by
the way i would love love love love to
see a new some desantis
uh
presidential election i would love that
by the way i i would love to get the
biden trump situation yeah let's close
that chapter let's let some 40 and 50
year olds i love that and let the market
decide i love that let the market decide
who do you think be honest who do you
think i think that uh desantis would be
the favorite i think so too and i'd love
to see that let's get some new ideas get
some fresh ideas bring your california
bring your florida stuff and let let's
have a real intellectual debate you guys
should have seen that when i was in when
i was in cali when the nuke the new some
recall was going on i've never seen that
many people out loud at the gas station
and [ __ ] like just pissed off they're
just angry they were just like we gotta
get this you know guy the hell out of
there and i think larry alvarez was like
no they still lost i mean he landed by a
landslide but people that were scared to
talk were coming out and just openly
saying like what the hell is these but
that again going back to my point that
is the most loyal party the the the the
laugh and cali i would be they go down
everybody to california 100
i would be i would i would do this i
would do a press conference and i would
say
governor newsom uh i'd like to uh at no
cost to your state at all
you don't need to pay me a salary i'm
not gonna take money away from your tax
revenues that you're bringing in don't
worry about any of that stuff consider
me
your chief recruiting officer okay
exactly strategy and here's what i'd
like to say and who are you who are you
saying this happens to news okay okay
and if you if you're the following and
i'm gonna go through it if you like this
if you like this i highly
highly recommend
you move to california highly recommend
go there if you like these following
things
um anyways
listen people in california like you
know how you're saying
you just said right now i was in the gas
station i was in this i was in that i
was in this i was the night like oh my
god you know everybody wanted this guy
out not really not in california they
did not okay the people that the core
core people that live in california out
the part when i said on worldstar when
biden put that up and 99 of all the
people trashed him that's america to me
okay believe it or not to me that's more
america than what california thinks
because that to me is not america
that's california california is like
france it's only yeah it's it's its own
country you know there's a game behind
the game here to step back from this to
look at what newsom is trying to do
here's a game where is the money for the
presidential elections is it in the
individual campaigns or is it a dnc it's
a dnc because when you win the primary
the dnc's got the big treasure chest and
they drive that hard but the dnc also
controls the green lighting system of
whether you're allowed to primary a
sitting president in your own party
right now they need the midterm election
to be done and it's going to be bad they
need q3 economic it's going to be bad
they need the q4 economic report and
it's probably going to be bad with those
three items pat mark my words the dnc
will suddenly
subtly
allow
formal primary activities against biden
right now the dnc will not permit it
they will not permit you to go up
against a sitting president what newsom
is doing is he's testing because he's
going to test this and they're going to
run all those phone calls if you've ever
taken
a political phone call did you see
recently uh someone so said so-and-so
yeah how did you think about that how
did and they asked you they're going to
be testing this to see how this
campaign speech this stump speech that
he just did worked against desantis and
they're going to be making the case hey
listen we're the only viable candidate
kamala harris not her no we're the
viable candidate you need to be behind
us you need to allow the green lighting
process to happen you need to allow me
to start doing you know primary work in
earnest and when the dnc behind closed
doors subtly says
okay gavin you can um you can start
preparing primary bash against that's
when it will happen have you ever
noticed that all of a sudden you go from
speculative iowa candidates to suddenly
there would be
there would be actually validated iowa
candidates in both political parties
that's when the rnc dnc step up
and that's when they that's when the big
dollars start to come out now you have
to raise money as a campaign but there's
bigger dollars behind you and
newsom is campaigning
less against desantis right now pat but
he's campaigning against biden with the
dnc
to be the guy they get behind if they're
going to primary as sitting president so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]